jetzt wird wirklich eine grenze
überschritten einem internationalen
forschungsteam ist es gelungen eine
hürde für die transplantation von
schweine organ in menschen zu
eliminieren
sie kommen das erbgut der schweine die
dna so verändern dass die dna von für
den menschen schädlichen viren darin
ausgeschaltet wurde
den technik macht es möglich der mensch
wird mit solchen organen zur schimäre
zum mischwesen aus zwei organismen sind
schweine organ in zukunft also die
lösung für kranke und wollen wir das
überhaupt die antworten darauf jetzt
wichtigsten fiction herzlich willkommen
10.000 schwerkranke menschen in
deutschland haben wohl nur noch eine
chance zu überleben wenn sie eine
organspende einen anderen menschen
bekommen viele von ihnen werden wohl
vorher sterben bis ein für sie passendes
organ gefunden wird forschungsteam
weltweit forschen daran dass auch ihre
organe diesen menschen helfen könnten
doch noch gibt es dabei sehr viele
probleme wie etwa abstoßungsreaktionen
das heißt was das immunsystem die organ
abstößt auf schweine kämen als
organspender für uns menschen in
betracht doch ende der 90er jahre wurden
viren im genom der schweine
identifiziert die wohl gefährlich für
den menschen sein können das problem
dabei diese retroviren sind in das
erbgut der tiere ag.ma integriert sie
könnten sich also im menschlichen genom
würde den ab festsetzen wenn ein schwein
herz dann in den menschlichen körper
eingesetzt würde diese portionen
endogenen retroviren kurz so heißen die
viren könnten dort immundefekte und
krebs verursachen einen internationalen
wissenschafts team ist nun das gelungen
woran viele andere vor ihnen gescheitert
waren nämlich diese retroviren
unschädlich zu machen das team eines
private us-unternehmen takt mit hilfe
von gentechnik und 30 verkehr schaffen
die frei von diesen retroviren waren
dafür nutzen sie die kursprognose quasi
eine gentechnische schere mit der durch
im erbgut von lebewesen beliebiger
umschneiden lag wir hatten ja bei diesen
zwei pcs vor kurzem berichtet dass
forscherinnen und forscher damit zuletzt
sogar gesunde menschliche embryonen
gezüchtet hatten
den hatten sie vorher mit hilfe von
chris barth künstlich einen gen-defekt
entfernt zurück zu den forschungen rund
um die schweine hatten auf denjenigen
fällen die entsprechend verändert wurden
erzeugten embryonen ohne diese per fax
ohne diese viren 200 bis 300 davon
sondern jeweils einer mutter übertragen
das ergebnis 37 werke mit inaktiven per
das team feiert das als großen erfolg
macht hoffnungen auf weitere
sensationelle erfolge
man wolle nun den per freien schweine
stammen weiter entwickeln um damit dann
sicher und wirksam
dass schweine herz in einen menschen zu
verpflanzen der fachbegriff dafür
kino transplantation noch gibt es
zahlreiche schwierigkeiten zu überwinden
konnten primaten nicht lange überleben
denen gentechniker schweine organe
eingesetzt hatten
alle der sehr wenigen versuche schweine
hatten den menschen zu transportieren
sind ausnahmslos gescheitert denn das
menschliche immunsystem bekämpft fremdes
gewebe selbst das von anderen menschen
medikamente die das verhindern haben
zahlreiche nebenwirkungen schon bei
transplantationen von menschlichen
organen hinzu kommt ein weiteres problem
das schweineherzen mit sich bringen die
rechte herzkammer zum beispiel punkt
schwächer als die der menschen dass du
den ergebnis klingt sicher erst mal sehr
spannend doch viele fragen bleiben noch
offen abzuwarten weit beispielsweise wie
lange die gezüchteten ferkel ohne die
retroviren im genom überleben werden
gesetzt weiß man nämlich noch nicht
sicher ob sie diese zum überleben
brauchen
aber was ist wenn sie weiterleben und
dann noch ein weg gefunden wird die
schweineherzen gentechnisch so zu
verändern dass der mensch sie besser
aufnehmen kann das nicht verarbeiten den
menschen zu diesem ganzen außerdem
tragen kommt ein weiterer aspekt hinzu
der moralische wildschweine als
ersatzteillager für menschen vertretbar
und wo führt uns das alles hin
die techniken des genommen editing sind
alle noch sehr neu und unverstanden
auch wenn sie in irgendeiner art und
weise funktionieren kann heutzutage
niemand abschätzen was das langfristig
für uns bedeutet wenn wir menschen die
evolution west in die hand nehmen wir
müssen uns die frage stellen ob wir das
verantworten wollen was man hier ich bin
auf eure meinung in den kommentaren
gespannt wenn es neues zum thema gibt
dann halte ich euch natürlich hier
praktikum auf dem laufenden und wenn ihr
kein video zu diesem und vielen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann wird mir
hier genau ein abo aufs auge und
vergesst nicht den genau auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit werden gehen
soldaten jetzt realität da geht es genau
um die genmanipulation an menschlichen
embryonen wenn euch dieses video hier
gefahr entweder band ist das vielleicht
noch spannender also drauf kriegen viel
spaß dabei und ansonsten bestand bleibt
dran